LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
This is an incredible place
with lots of great stuff being
worked on every single day.
Before I worked here,
I always wondered
what it would be like to
come to the Googleplex,
meet up with a Googler,
and have coffee with them
and just chat about what
they do, how they do it,
and why they do it.
And today, we're going
to do exactly that.
Hi.
And welcome to this episode
of Coffee with a Googler.
Today, we're reporting actually
from inside Google's Cloud
itself, or at least one of the
data centers that powers it.
And I'm meeting
with Greg Wilson.
He's a manager on the Developer
Advocacy Team for the Google
Cloud Platform.
But he's not one of your
typical pointy haired managers.
You've worked on
lots of cool stuff.
And you're going to tell
us all about it today.
GREG WILSON: You bet.
Yep, thanks for having me.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So tell us
what is it that you do here?
GREG WILSON: So I manage a team
of people, developer advocates,
for Google Cloud Platform.
There's about 18 of us total.
And our job is to go
out into the world
and make sure people know all
the cool things that we're
doing with cloud platform.
It's innovating very quickly--
announcements every other week.
And we try to get
the word out there.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now
there's a lot of diversity
around cloud developers.
There are so many different
types of developers.
And it must be really hard
to have a core message
to reach all of them.
What are the opportunities
to reach out?
GREG WILSON: Yeah, it is.
It's very unique for
our team, specifically,
in Google is that we're
dealing with a platform that
has a different meaning to a
lot of different audiences.
So for example, no JS
developers see cloud
in a specific way,
certain parts of cloud
that meet their needs for apps.
Similar with Ruby, Java.
But even things like
data scientists,
people that are looking at six
billion rows of transit data
and they want to draw some
intelligence out of that.
So we're trying to get them
interested in it as well.
It's cool.
We have some amazing services
around all of those things.
So it's not just that we talk
to developers in one language.
We have to be able to speak
in multiple types of languages
to multiple types of audiences.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
that's quite a challenge.
But you've got a big team,
well equipped team for it.
GREG WILSON: It is.
And it's fun too.
Because you get to see a
lot of interesting things
that people are
doing when you're
providing the computing
power, the CPUs,
to drive all this stuff.
You see some pretty
amazing things.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Now, you mentioned
that you're constantly
releasing new things.
And there's a constant drumbeat
of great new technologies
coming out.
What kind of recent
ones have you done?
GREG WILSON: Gosh, so
many things going on.
The recent ones that we've been
doing some activity around-- we
have 32 CPU VMs now.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice, nice.
GREG WILSON: Matter
of fact, one of them
is 208 gigabytes of
memory with 32 CPUs.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Virtual.
GREG WILSON: Yeah, that's the
gadget guy inside of me just
loves that, having
all this computing
power at my fingertips.
And it's one thing to
think about a 32 CPU VM,
that you start thinking about
that in terms of clusters.
I want to have 1,000 of
those doing something.
It's mind boggling
what you can do.
And it's exciting for us.
And we try to share
that excitement
with the people we talk to.
And then around the
same time, we also
introduced a new feature
called local SSDs.
So it's extremely high
I/O bandwidth drives
that are physically connected
to your virtual machine.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
GREG WILSON: We're talking
170,000 sustained IOPS, which
if you know anything about
disk drives and hardware,
that's a stunning number.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
And I know you've been
putting all this together
to try and come up
with some scenarios
that you can show it off,
that numbers of CPUs an IOPS
might not mean much
to other folks.
But the other stuff that
you've been building does.
So can you share that?
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
And that's one of the
challenges of our team,
is that how do we let people
know beyond the specs?
We can show them
a lot of numbers
of what the stuff is about.
But until they can see the kind
of things you can do with it,
it doesn't really make
sense to them sometimes.
So yeah, we're always thinking
about how can we show this off?
What type of demos can we build?
What kind of story can we
build, more importantly?
For example, when the
32 CPU DMs launched,
we found some software
called Prime C that
generates prime numbers,
using some neat very simple
algorithms.
And we generated a trillion
prime numbers in 17 minutes
on a 32 CPU machine.
LAURENCE MORONEY: A
trillion in 17 minutes.
GREG WILSON: A trillion, yeah.
And it was funny.
I tweeted about in.
And the tweet was, I generated
to trillion prime numbers.
Because I can.
Why not?
LAURENCE MORONEY: And you
said it took 17 minutes.
GREG WILSON: 17
minutes for that.
The software, thankfully,
supports multi-core.
So it was able to take
advantage of those 32 CPUs.
It's really very much a
CPU intensive operation
where there's other things that
also take advantage of memory.
And you can mix and match a
lot of the things that we offer
and compute to do that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now, to rent
a 32 CPU machine for 17 minutes-
how much would that cost?
GREG WILSON: Well thankfully,
we have the per minute billing
on that.
I think the hourly rate for the
208 gig one is anywhere from
a buck, 65, to 2.10
an hour, or something.
It's really
inexpensive considering
what you're getting.
And that's part of
the Google scale.
I mean, we were able to pass on
that scale in incredible cost
savings.
And so what that means
for geeks like me
is that I can get my hands
on some serious hardware
for the price of
a cup of coffee.
I have a lot of
fun in 17 minutes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah,
that trillion prime numbers
must've been pennies at the
rate you just mentioned.
It's incredible.
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
So what is that, 1/4 of 2 bucks?
So yeah, 50 cents.
LAURENCE MORONEY: How many
universities, and stuff,
have to go and invest hundreds
of thousands of dollars
in infrastructure when
you can do it this way?
GREG WILSON: Yeah, exactly.
And that's the whole
idea behind cloud.
And that's why there's so
much excitement in cloud,
not just Google, but a lot of
the other big names in cloud
doing the same thing.
It's a very exciting space,
which is what drew me into it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And you
took this sort of next step
on pay day.
I've heard some of the stuff
you've been doing for that.
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
So sort of a funny story--
one of the guys on my team,
Ray Tsang-- he and I were
at South by Southwest
with some other
folks from Google.
South by Southwest
was a few weeks ago
in Austin, Texas--
fantastic event.
And we were literally hanging
out at a bar, 11:00 p.m.
At night.
LAURENCE MORONEY: When
all the best ideas happen.
GREG WILSON: When all
the best ideas happen--
having a couple of drinks.
And someone mentioned that
the following day was Pi Day.
And Ray and I were
like, man, I wonder
if we could do
something with Pi Day
like we did with
the prime numbers.
And we said, well,
first of all, we
got to have some
software that can do it.
We have ours.
We can't go write software
to generate digits of pi.
Plus, it's not trivial.
It's pretty advanced
mathematics.
So we both have our phones out.
And we're Googling, is there
any software available?
And sure enough, we found
this thing called y-cruncher,
by a gentleman
named Alexander Lee.
It supports multi-core.
It will allow you
to generate digits
of pi up to an astronomical
number of digits.
So it supported the
operating system that we had.
It ran on Linux.
It was very CPU intensive
and memory intensive,
a good story for our VMs.
So at 11:00 PM, we
were facing a choice.
Do we do we run back to the
hotel and sit in the lobby
and make this work?
Or do we sit here and continue
drinking with their friends?
Because we're geeks first.
And we basically were in
a cab in five minutes.
So we excitedly get into a cab.
We go back.
We spent several hours
experimenting with it.
So we were able to do a
billion just in minutes.
I mean, it was incredibly fast.
And we were looking
at how do our VMs
work with this the best?
And well, a billion is
not that impressive.
And so well, why don't
we try 10 billion.
So we did 10 billion.
And that ran pretty
fast as well.
But we still didn't feel like
we really stretched things.
So they we tried 100 billion.
Well, the problem
with 100 billion
is that it needs a lot more
memory than the 208 gig.
So we needed to provide
disk for swapping.
And as you know, disks are
much, much slower than memory.
LAURENCE MORONEY: SSD
is not bad, right?
GREG WILSON: Exactly.
And with local SSDs, which
are these physically connected
devices to your VM,
they're extremely fast.
So that's where the 170,000
IOPS comes into play.
So we thought hey, here's
a great opportunity.
We're about 12:05
AM at this point.
So now we're playing around.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
it's only an hour in.
GREG WILSON: Oh yeah.
We're still just
getting started.
So we provision
out the local SSDs.
We fire up a VM
with them connected.
And we play around with the
parameters of the software.
And we had 1.5 terabytes
of local SSD connected.
Because not only do you
need it for the swap,
but the output file itself.
If you're going to generate
100 billion digits of pi,
that's 800 billion characters
in a file somewhere.
So we actually dabbled with
doing a trillion digits.
But it was going
to take more time.
It was going to
go beyond Pi Day.
LAURENCE MORONEY: You
needed to go to bed.
GREG WILSON: And we were
getting sleepy at this point.
So anyway, Ray's on one laptop.
I'm on the other.
We're experimenting with
different parameters.
And we found the perfect mix.
And thankfully, this is
right in Ray's wheel house.
So we made a great team on this.
And so about 3:00
AM, we kick off
what we think is
going to be the job.
And we call it a night.
And so the next
morning, we excitedly
logged back into the terminal.
And it had finished.
And it ran at about
5.3 hours and generated
100 billion digits.
LAURENCE MORONEY: 100
billion in five hours, wow.
GREG WILSON: So then
we did a fun tweet.
In celebration of
pi day, Ray and I
generated 100
billion digits of pi.
And we put it out there.
And this is getting back to
the developer advocacy job.
We're trying to
generate some buzz
and show people
the cool things you
can do with this technology
and this platform.
And the tweet did really well.
I mean, it took off.
It caught in some of the
excitement of Pi Day.
[INAUDIBLE] was
tweeting about Pi Day.
We were really hoping he
would catch our tweet.
And a few people actually
pointed him to it.
But he's probably got
other things on his mind.
LAURENCE MORONEY: He's
probably watching our show now.
GREG WILSON: Yeah,
I'm sure he will.
So he missed his opportunity.
The next Pi Day
will be his makeup.
So that was a fun day.
We got a good amount
of buzz out of that.
We high fived.
Because that was developer
advocacy success.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
It's a big win, right?
GREG WILSON: So now we want
to take it to the next level
and try to break some
records on speed.
On the site that has
y-cruncher, there
are documented records of how
long it takes to do these.
We actually broke a couple of
records with what we're doing.
But we don't want to
publish those yet.
Because we want to go
for a bigger record.
So we want to do a
trillion digits next.
That's very feasible.
But the world record
for pi is 13.3 trillion.
The current record was
done on a workstation
with nearly 300 terabytes of
drives attached to it for swap.
And it ran for 208 days.
But that's a workstation
with a bunch of drives.
I've got Google data
centers at my fingertips.
I should be able to
beat that, right?
So it's more challenging
than you might think.
So we're going to
be working on that.
So hopefully, we'll be talking
a few months about how we now
hold the world record.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
We'll be celebrating
you breaking the record.
GREG WILSON: We'll
see what happens.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And when
you did the 100 billion
for five hours, again, just
thinking in terms of cost--
because it's just the two of
you on your laptops terminalling
into a cloud server somehow.
And compared to having the
dedicated hardware for it,
the cost must've
been a lot lower.
GREG WILSON: Oh, yeah.
It was cheaper
than the two drinks
we were drinking
when we left the bar.
For the Pi Day specifically,
the local SSDs,
we only charged for the storage
for the drives themselves.
You don't get charged
for the bandwidth.
Because they're
physically connected.
And then the virtual machine
is the pricing per minute.
LAURENCE MORONEY: You
have it for five hours.
GREG WILSON: Right,
so you're looking--
I mean-- no more than
$15, probably little
less than 15 bucks.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So it wasn't
even particularly expensive
drinks?
GREG WILSON: No, it wasn't.
And that's the beauty of this.
And we're having fun with this.
There's not a lot
of practical use
to this other than some buzz.
But you think about a lot of
the research that's going on
and a lot of the computing
power that's needed.
And especially when you start
thinking beyond a single VM,
and you think, that times 1,000
or 10,000 VMs in a cluster,
you can really start doing
some game changing things.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Absolutely.
Sounds cool.
GREG WILSON: Now for folks
who are watching the show who
might want to start
dabbling in this
and maybe calculate
some other numbers,
how would they get started?
What's a good place?
GREG WILSON: Best starting place
is just go to cloud.google.com.
We actually have a trial
that you can sign up for.
You get $300 for a couple
of months of playing
around, $300 for 60 days.
You can have a lot
of fun with $300,
I mean, just based on
what we just talked about.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's 20
times your pi calculations.
GREG WILSON: Yeah, you could
do a lot of digits of pi.
Hopefully, you
would do something
more exciting than that.
So you can't missed
the free trial button.
It's everywhere.
And there is documentation.
I mean, we've only touched
on virtual machines.
We're starting to do a
lot of exciting stuff
around containers with
a container engine,
BigQuery, the very large data
analysis that we mentioned
earlier, Kubernetes project.
There are so many amazing
things going on in cloud
that I think people would be
surprised what we're doing.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
And it's all summarized
on cloud.google.com.
GREG WILSON: It is, yep,
everything you can find.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thanks, Greg.
That was so cool--
lots of great stories.
GREG WILSON: Thanks.
I appreciate you having me.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Well thanks everybody
for watching this episode
of Coffee with a Googler.
For more great videos on
Google Developer topics,
and on Google Cloud and
everything else that we do,
take a look at the
Google Developers channel
and subscribe to us.
If any questions
for me or if you
have any questions for
Greg, please leave them
in the comments below.
And thanks so much.